hey wide crack Jared here today we're
talking about everyone's favorite
psychopath a man who's one twirly
mustache away from being a hipster the
mayor of pipi pad city pee pee pants
City reals negan and yes there are
spoilers ahead despite being people
atheist antagonist of the show negan
gets an inordinate amount of praise from
fan
negan is hard not to love in part
because he's just so damn charming I
just let my dick down your throat and
you thanked me for it might not just be
his undeniable charisma that makes us
gravitate towards him he is one of the
most effective leaders of the post
apocalypse but the real question is how
effective exactly sure we could leave it
at not very because of course someone is
going through murder overthrow him why
cuz well this has all happened before
but I digress negan's cruelty is neither
novel nor irrational but a little help
from philosophy in psychology we can
better understand how negan is the
perfect dictator
welcome is wide-track edition on the
philosophy of negan a leader especially
a post-apocalyptic one can spend all day
putting people in their place rooting
out insurrection as it appears and
ahhing people with the occasional
spectacle of violence but a much more
effective dictator to get people to
police them self and negan is a master
of this craft negan is terrifying as
many dictators are but what defines his
terror is his seeming omnipresent he's
everywhere and always watching
in fact the finale of season 6 is like
one giant proof of concept for this
negan saviors let rick's gang leave
they've somehow evaded them with subtle
reminders that they're always one step
ahead of them
negan even admits that the whole thing
was orchestrated to strike fear into
them I want you to think about what
could have happened
think about what happened and think
about what can still happen Meghan's
method isn't so different from a system
devised by English philosopher Jeremy
Bentham for prisons a design that would
make it impossible for a prisoner to
know whether or not the guards were
watching him the pre electronic
equivalent of CCTV it was called the
pentacon from the Greek term for
all-seeing French philosopher Michel
Foucault said that Bentham
panopticon was power reduced to its
ideal form kind of political technology
when people are always but maybe not
under surveillance they internalize
disciplinary power they become their own
police
negan takes panoptic power and infuses
it with his own brand of Lucille infused
terror she she is a stickler for the
rules Darrell tries to escape but soon
realizes it was all a ploy the door was
left on lock to encourage Daryl's escape
only to be surrounded by negan when he's
on the cusp of freedom we piss it off
and yeah
on one level this is pure psychological
manipulation causing Daryl and the
viewer to question reality this is a
chance to escape or an elaborate trap it
also inculcates and Daryl this kind of
pen optic terror negan is always
watching whether you realize it or not
so you best stay in line I am everywhere
it's for this reason that negan is so
obsessed with finding the missing guns
from Alexandria where are my guns sure
it's part I don't want team Rick to use
them to shoot me but it's also to
further ingrain the point you can't hide
anything from negan there Oman now even
saviors are constantly fearful for what
negan will find out negan followers
saying I am negan reinforces this
constant surveillance we are all me
there's no one to confide in no one to
trust because they all have become
little satellites of surveillance who
are ya even we the viewer have managed
to internalize negan's terror reeling
from the loss of one of the few
characters we still give a [ __ ] about we
all collectively clenched our buttholes
when people break the rules
negan has achieved the goals of
Bentham's panopticon without the actual
technology he breaks people with his
campaign of terror that wasn't so bad
now was it to break someone is to
internalize me instead of rule Bentham's
panopticon doesn't break prisoners in
the same terrifying way but the goal is
the same to make people police
themselves to behave as if someone else
is watching whether or not they actually
are play by their rules we get some kind
of life the perfect example of this is
Dwight who admits the Darryl that he too
thought he would never kneel to negan
now he fully embodies negan's rules
despite the fact he shows clear signs of
hating him but violence and surveillance
alone don't provide the best beans for
controlling people people find ways to
be unseen and even when they're being
watched don't go on performing their
jobs to the best of their ability but
negan is smarter than that
negan is part twentieth-century
totalitarian and also part 21st century
corporate manager he understands talent
development today was career day we
invested a lot you know who I am and
what I can do those razón enough to defy
him are often spared
while their friends are killed instead
their rebellious tendencies are raw
talent for savior inks to develop I want
to get to know more call he's also
keenly aware of the dangers of
talentless sycophant cutting out yes-man
before they ruin the corporate culture
negan knows the secret sauce of
motivation and as a result he does more
than just punish people he rewards them
negan's response to people may seem
erratic as if his bouts of violence are
driven by his temper but I'd like to
argue that it's all very deliberate he's
developed a whole point system to
incentivize work and while consistent
rewards are a great way to motivate
people it can all be your psychologist
argue that there's an even better way to
get people to do [ __ ] reward them
randomly behavioral psychologists have
found that when rewards are unexpected
and unscheduled they are far more
effective in promoting certain behaviors
don't just buy a worker a cup of coffee
every time he hits a deadline or every
fifth time make it a surprise if you
don't believe me go play a slot machine
random bonuses and treasures will keep
you playing for hours and this is what
negan does all the time since you're
doing such an awesome job you want to
have a little blast from the past with
you-know-who
there's also Carl's stay with Meegan
where it's not only physical rewards but
emotional niceties that are randomly
doled out Carl kills [ __ ] people and
expects to die or be mutilated but
instead negan takes them in and commends
his badass rage but not to overdo the
kindness he makes Carl take off his eye
covering makes fun of him that is gross
as hell but that apologizes when it goes
too far
neener you're feeling Nick and then
asked Carl to sing a song at the threat
of violence stern singing and
intersperses violent bats wings with
complement with pretty good
this strategy generally and
unfortunately work and if vegan seems
like an abusive boyfriend he should this
random reinforcement is also used by
abusive partners to keep their victims
in relationships no must oh please you
like me any one another way to
understand Egon is through the lens of
sweat stain t-shirt aficionado slab
logic and his works on totalitarianism
far from imposing on us a firm set of
standards to be complied with jiseok
says the totalitarian master suspends
moral punishment his secret injunction
is you may this is negan to a tee
the Savior's are like a well-ordered
anarchy aside from the rules to which
negan constantly refers his followers
are free to murder and pillage according
to the judge the totalitarian master
tells us that the prohibitions which
regulate social life and guarantee a
minimum of decency are worthless
just as advice to keep common people at
bay we on the other hand are free to let
ourselves go to kill rape plunder but
only insofar as we follow the master
brunettes lenss- dictatorship makes
perfect sense in context of the real
world totalitarian government people's
deepest desires are pander to so long as
they don't conflict with the ruling
establishment want to steal and murder
go to town [ __ ] the rule just don't [ __ ]
with my rules so negan is a pretty
effective dictator but is he an
effective ruler the problem with
heavy-handed dictatorship is that it
breeds problems the kind of problems
were sure to see as Rick Ezekiel and
maybe even Dwight rebel against negan
it's the same problem of real-life
dictatorships that are constantly
threatened by assassination plot
insurrections and so on maybe negan
should have brushed up on his
Machiavelli who famously said he who
becomes master of a city accustomed to
freedom and does not destroy it may
expect to be destroyed by it what do you
guys think has negan perfected the
science of control or is he just sowing
the seeds of his own demise
hey everyone thanks a lot for watching
I've got our editor Ryan here again
what's up wisecrack so last time we read
some comments you guys seem to like it
so we're here to do it again so Ryan
tell me what the people are saying first
we're gonna start it off on a positive
note we got silver banded on our
philosophy of Rick and Morty episode he
said this was honestly the most
depressing video I've watched all day
most of my life my life I've been told
I'm important and I matter until I was
reminded I'm a speck of dust floating on
a rock in a vacuum well silver bandit if
it makes you feel any better than a
meaningless universe your sadness means
nothing as well one of our last Walking
Dead videos someone named Ames commented
what separates us from animals and
zombies there is the one thing that does
this the ability to question and
actually Ames wrote a whole lot more you
can freeze-frame adhere to read the
whole thing but that's kind of the
thesis yeah I mean these are the kind of
comments that we love to see you know
start conversations on the channel that
sounds pretty legit to me Ames did
generate a pretty good discussion on the
first comment on two Eames was by Joey
and he said shut up [ __ ] in response to
that to the whole paragraph yes
but they had something to jelly yeah
thank you for contributing Joey those
are the kind of comments that we well
yeah we'll take you on our South Park
references video T Christian 0 for said
living in a post stack society where
there's a constant war of narratives
going on seems to me to be a natural
symptom of postmodern philosophy why I
be concerned with facts when
post-modernism undermines objective
truth
why not fight for your preferred
narrative when post-modernism eliminates
the meta-narrative it's a whole lot to
chew on I actually has a conversation of
one of our writers recently and I
brought up post-modernism in the context
of post fact and they got really
offended I think that people in academia
like you know if you claim that
post-modernism is at all you know
related to the whole post bacc thing
they get like really defensive they
would say it's just a big bastardization
of post-modernism
on our South Park references video
Alberto Medina had the comment bill
Kanger zero nine 9's Adisa deep vivid
Gaghan off kapu e riwa ACMA halo videos
XY had to hustle go walk as Vinc to
death ad
you just need to say about that turd
[ __ ] yeah okay also on the South Park
references video our old friend
ot7 4:6 one says do the philosophy of
filthy Frank this is my 16th petition ok
I've seen your comment many times I got
to be honest I have checked out filthy
Frank and I think there might be
something to say so look out for that
alright I think that's it for now those
are some awesome comments keep them
coming everybody
well before you go if you want to get
access to exclusive content from us to
go check out our patreon page here
you'll get access to a racy episode that
we actually has a pull off of youtube
plus I'm thinking about posting some
rants on our patreon page I've got a
great rant about how much I hate the
movie Suicide Squad so I'm going to post
that and make it exclusive patrons so
check it out that's coming around the
corner and finally if you want more
Walking Dead shoot this zombie in the
head to check out our other video on the
philosophy of the show it's that's over
a million views I'm sure you'll love it
alright until next time guys peace bye
you
[Music]